[Music]
welcome to the iron lords podcast
hey everyone how you doing lord petey
here uh just wanted to give everyone
another ilp first look at this game
called weird west
now weird west kind of uh came up uh
because a lot of people have been
streaming it and i wanted to kind of see
how it looked and see how it played and
it looked kind of fun uh because you
know it's the wild west how can you not
enjoy fun in the wild west and uh what
we end up learning is that uh you know
i'm not that far in the game itself but
uh
what i ended up coming to uh to see is
how
um
you play as this
uh is this
uh former
um
uh sheriff of a town uh who ends up uh
their family ends up dying uh due to
some outlaws and uh what your objective
in in life is is to go out uh to find
those um
to find those people and uh bring them
to justice and as you're going through
you learn more and more about more
supernatural type things happening um so
far i've uncovered there has been like
werewolves
all over uh and it's kind of very
interesting the the gameplay so um the
gameplay is you know point-and-cl uh
point-and-shoot
you can hide behind rocks and and use
grenades you have upgrades you have
different weapons uh and you can upgrade
those weapons so there's lots of
different tiers in this game now the
reason why it really piqued my interest
when i was playing it was because
the game has a really really cool art
style which i really really enjoyed um
another option you know your character
you know the moves around the screen
pretty fluidly and and and pretty uh
seamlessly uh as you know the other
characters are moving and i and you have
this
top-down uh type of view um to see
what's going on and i really think it's
uh it's really really good uh the story
campaign so far is really really neat uh
you're going through the story and
you're trying to find out what happened
to your family uh spoilers which you
learn in the first 30 seconds
and then from there you end up
proceeding to you know go after outlaws
after outlaws shooting them killing them
and trying you know trying to figure out
what's going on uh
and eventually you know you want to get
friends so you end up you know hiring
deputies and you end up uh going out on
bounty hunts to uh to get more people uh
once you kill more people you end up
getting more money through those
bounties
um to be able to move around in the map
faster you can buy a horse so there's
all these different dynamics in the game
which gives it a little more depth which
i really really did enjoy playing and i
really really think it's a very unique
and enjoyable game
i'm really really curious to see
you know where they're where they are
right now and where they're going to be
going to uh with this game because
they've already stated that it is um you
know their first build and they're gonna
start making it larger and larger and
better now i'm not too sure that it is
in early access but uh i'm pretty sure
this is a full-fledged game um that you
can end up playing and there's gonna be
more things on the roadmap to come and i
really really can't wait to see what's
happening there so i just wanted to uh
show everyone you know a clip of this
game and really the combat and what's
going on with it i really think you all
should check it out so uh it's really
really great uh it's called weird west
uh go check it out and i will see you
all soon all right this is uh lord petey
here um if you're looking for me uh lord
pdtv on twitch monday through friday uh
on all social medias
um i'm there and then uh you know make
sure you check the iron lord's podcast
out on sundays and then again if you're
looking uh to get all your gaming news
check lords of gaming.net where everyone
is uh you know awesome and works their
uh their butts to show
you you know the insides and outs of
many different games so thanks again and
have a fantastic day bye everybody
oh
i definitely did not expect to use that
many bandages and i fight
but that got a little nasty
uh
that is not what i wanted i wanted to
put up that
so i can sell it
get rid of it for the shelves
he blew up his own ass
um
oh come on no no i don't want to see the
cam like that no no no
so apparently
we're not gonna care
trap door
light it
i love it i was just gonna have like
random gun
slugs all over town
oh
you perks
oh his hat just flew right off
boom
get out of here
[Music]
we just scrap it from there
that's good
oh
i could watch
uh
do that
well health
ruffle rounds on the ground
gonna end up on a dinner plate listen
you get going my friend i'm gonna need
your assistance
what is that purple
okay
oh
oh great
i'm always a big fan when they give you
a bunch of weapons right before
just hire myself
here's some rare items in one of these
graves you might like
it was the grave with someone named
andrew i hope you can get him up by the
circuits back
[Music]
okay
secret stash
oh my god that is so far away
get to run and get your cardio
wrangler's gonna help you destroy easily
just blow them up or lock pick em
or
find the seller key
dude bauero
hold on
oh
gold ore
oh man
he was dead i think you're fast enough
taking objects
boom
for sparta
are you coming this way
coming this way
i'm gonna shoot you if you do
don't want to waste my ammo
but i will
but i will
gonna knock you out
and drop you on the ground
give me all your stuff
uh
i can't even borrow you
oh we just walked into that one
i need to
i have more than one machete huh
what about the corpse
like i purposely did that
i didn't know if we were gonna get
another guy or not we got like a whole
plethora of greater foes
think you've been outclassed about is
good again what's your frozen counter in
the wild west
have even more affordable
variations which you can identify with
insignia around their names hmm
oh yeah i made him a corpse
what do you want regular
i'm not gonna lie i don't know
oh
look right at me
got him
[Music]
you